I'm a movie gu I'm going to give you
some movies that I like and I want you
to think I want you right to see if you
like the movies or not why'd you look at
your publicist I wasn't I was just doing
I was just doing a look for the camera
like you're top five you're top five I'm
going to give you my top five see if you
think it's it's you like the movies
Human Centipede no no one of my favorite
movies of all time what do you what do
you think of Paris Texas oh V venders I
like Paris Texas but the problem was I
got I saw Paris Texas at a point in film
School were if I was not completely
obsessed with Paris Texas or down by law
or Mystery Train there were certain
movies that were in the film School
NYU like you better like Down By Law you
better like Trust In The Unbelievable
Truth by Hal heartley and you [__]
better like wings of desire in Paris
Texas and I remember watching the
American friend going whoa this is
really interesting and Paris Texas is a
beautiful film and I also like that
Allison Andre was a PA on it so her
movie Grace of my heart like all of her
films like she made but she was a PA and
her like Vim vanders was her kind of her
God and so she made her movies to
basically try to be in the spirit if
you've ever seen an Allison Anders film
it's like she's the most heavily
influenced by Paris Texas it's a
beautiful movie I love Nastasia kinsky I
mean you can't all right it's a great
film being there well yeah you can't joh
yeah being there you know I like to
watch I love I love Hal Ashby Hal Ashby
is one of my cinema Gods I mean he's you
know when I when I started the first one
of his films I saw was Harold and mod oh
yeah the great and then I love The Last
Detail but shampoo is so good have you
seen never saw shampoo if you love once
upon a time in Hollywood like the sort
of there's a party sequence that's
famous like shampoo is very Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood 1976 Warren batty it's
Hal Ashby before before he did um it's
like it's it's 76 being there is 80
being there is a masterpiece have you
ever seen the loved one no the loved one
is a crazy F man loved one I want to
watch it tonight what what is it you may
have to watch this podcast so the loved
one is qu if you listen to qu podcast
they did a whole episode about it the
video archives podcast the loved one is
based on an EVN W novel that was written
by Terry Southern who wrote Doctor
Strange Love Tony my favorit Tony
Richardson directed this movie after he
won the Oscar for Tom Jones so this is
the classic thing of the person wins
best picture or best director and then
they get to do whatever they want
liberace's in it there's a scene in this
with r Rod stiger as Mr Joy boy and Hal
Ashby is an editor he's one of the
editors I think the editor of this film
wow so you can see Hal Ashby this movie
is so totally out there and completely
insane about the funeral industry in LA
but there's a scene with Rod stiger as
Mr Joy boy that like I've talked with
David David Lynch I was like you have to
be a fan of like oh my God Mr Joy boy
like when you look at the movies that we
love the well they're drinking from is
the loved one it's bananas it's great
wow yeah I've never even heard of it
it's a wild movie the loved ones yeah
loved one loved one yeah that the tag
the picture was something [__] the
picture was something to offend everyone
and yeah Liberace is a casket salesman
it's it's totally crazy have you ever
seen Lord love a duck no write that down
you should just the trailer for Lord
love a duck or you can just go up on
YouTube look up Lord love duck sweater
scene it's with Tuesday Weld and Ry
McDow play the world's oldest teenagers
I think I think Ry mcdow's
37 and it Geor Axel Rod Lord love a duck
is a batshit crazy movie with like an
amazing 60s theme but look up the just
watch the just Google there's a scene
where a father and daughter go sweater
shopping and that's the stuff I live for
it's like it's like you realize where
John Waters was inspired for pink
flamingos or desperate living you're
like you're watching Lord love it do I'm
like this Tuesday wild is so insanely
beautiful in it and her dad takes her
sweater shopping and it's and they're
eating hot dogs it's I can't even like
describe this movie it's so batshit
crazy but that's what I love is these
sort of obscure ones I always get really
interested those movies and then I was
like well what inspired Hal Ashby to
make being there and what inspired
Harold and ma
yeah yes
baby what is m m
yes pink put on p
on wow so I just love bat [__] crazy
like you're just like movies you're just
like how did this how diden I love those
so continue so I want to ask you being
there so being there parex being there
yeah but I also want to ask you
something that that I it's cuz I love
film but I don't know much okay seen a
lot I know some but I there but there's
probably [__] that I've just don't never
that's why you need like a super nerd
like me that's like kind of like a ask
give me three movies that I have to
watch in my lifetime oh man well it
depends let's let's go through your top
five and then it'll help me kind of
narrow well I mean CU my other ones are
like old boy I love Yeah well you've
seen sympathy for Mr Vengeance yeah one
of my favorite yeah love sympathy yeah I
love I saw the I like Korean movies
right I devil yeah yeah but do you like